Simplifica la expresión
28 por "a" cuadrado por "b" a las 6
entre 7 por "a" la 9 por "b"
¿Ok? Queremos simplificar
esta expresión y pues una buena forma de empezar
es dividir esta expresión en términos que nosotros ya sabemos que se pueden simplificar
más fácilmente, por ejemplo nosotros ya sabemos que
28 es divisible entre 7 y entonces nos va a quedar un entero que es más simple que una fracción.
Entonces lo primero que vamos a hacer es separar este 28 entre 7 ¿Ok? Pongámoslo por aquí.
28 entre 7
y eso está multiplicando al resto de la expresión
pero, este pedazo lo podemos partir en otros dos pedazos
que son más fáciles de simplificar ¿Ok? podemos tomar
este pedazo
entonces lo vamos a poner por aquí que es "a" cuadrada entre "a" a la
9 y el último pedazo que nos queda es este pedazo de aquí
que es "b" a la 6 entre "b" ¿Ok?.
Esto es
exactamente igual a esto de aquí, y la razón por la que hicimos todo esto,
es por que cada una de estas fracciones
es muy fácil de simplificar ¿Ok? 28 entre 7, sabemos que es igual a 4
y aquí lo que tenemos, son dos exponentes con exactamente la misma base y la base es "a".
Entonces para hacer esta división lo que hacemos es poner la misma base que es "a" tomar la
potencia del numerador que es este 2 y restarle la potencia del denominador que es este 9 ¿Ok?
Entonces tenemos 2 menos 9
y 2 -9 pues es -7.
Y lo mismo pasa con este término ¿Ok? Tenemos "b" a las 6
entre "b" elevado a la potencia 1.
¿Ok? Aunque aquí no se vea, esté "b" está elevado a la potencia 1
así es que, si dividimos "b" elevado a las 6 entre "b" elevado a la 1, lo que obtenemos es "b"
elevado a las 6 -1 que es
5 y listo hemos terminado, ya simplificamos esta expresión y su forma simplificada es esta de aquí.
Claro que podría no gustarnos tener exponentes negativos
entonces, vamos a reescribir esto como, el 4 lo dejamos igual
él "a" elevado a la -7 es igual a 1
entre "a" elevado a las 7 y nos falta multiplicar por "b" elevado a las 5,
¿Ok? Y a su vez esto también es igual a 4 por "b" elevado a las 5 entre
"a" elevado a las 7.